scarlet nexus is the upcoming anime
style action rpg from bandai namco
and we have some gameplay footage right
here so you can see the game in action
in a futuristic world threatened by
other worldly monsters called others
you have to put a stop to them you play
as either protagonist kasane or yuito
who have different paths within the same
story and you can see both of them
in action here you'll also have a merry
band of anime girls and boys
in a special forces unit who can support
you in combat but of course there seems
to be a deeper mystery to unravel in the
main story we got our hands on the game
for about three hours but we weren't
able to capture our own footage
so what you see here was provided by
bandai namco
scarlet nexus is set to launch on june
25th for pc
and xbox and playstation platforms you
can check out our full preview on
gamespot.com which is linked in the
description
box below and if you want more on the
latest in games do yourself a favor and
subscribe
enjoy
[Music]
so this is the pain of sas
this is fine i can handle it
[Music]
good seems like you're okay
this aptitude test will determine your
platoon assignment
do your best yes sir
[Music]
i heard you took down another major
other oh man
i wish i could have fought with you it
wasn't broadcast this time
weren't the crows there no a lot was
going on
city is really something it's the first
city of new hamuka
and the center of the government and the
military
yeah and being here means i won't miss
any information on baki merchandise
is that a good thing
[Music]
ah she looks so different from the way
they present her on tv
she's always lazy when she's not on
camera so a lot of people call her lazy
aura lazy ara
that suits her perfectly
[Music]
yuito want to talk i mean we're on the
same team now
okay but what do you want to talk about
we've known each other since we were
kids
you pretty much know everything about me
uh
you know
i haven't been on a relaxing walk like
this in a while
me neither i've been on missions
constantly since being assigned
we need to take time for ourselves like
this now and then
so anyway can i ask you something
sure what's up so
um what do you think about kasane
huh why are you suddenly bringing up
kasana
well you know we're catching up i wanted
to ask you something that must be on
your mind
and it seemed like you've been thinking
about kasane
a lot you haven't changed at all
really really i mean you're still into
bocky
but i'm a bit happy that you haven't
changed just staying being you
[Applause]
all right
here we go
come on
but it really feels like you're fighting
together
here we go
looks like there's a resource nearby
come on
um
your power is really great
[Music]
are you okay being what makes it hard to
move
it's done
you owe me
yeah it is the extinction belt's flow
changed during construction and now a
lot of
others appear there there aren't many
powerful others
but everyone should still be careful
are you nervous naomi your breathing is
getting a little shallow
oh yes a little done but i'm okay
just take deep breaths you're worried
about kasana
the enemy is attacking with electricity
you'll be shocked and unable to move if
it hits you
i can still fight
i need your help
it's done
huh
i guess we've got no choice let's go
all right i'm ready
this thing does look pretty tough yeah
oh look up there there's some material
hanging down
use your psychokinesis to slam it down
on its head
okay god
here we go
fireball
keep your eyes open you especially you
ito
your power lets you use the things
around you don't focus only on the enemy
in front of you
yes sir
here we go
is everyone okay
[Music]
[Music]
everyone get back now
i heard you took down another major
other oh man
i wish i could have fought with you it
wasn't broadcast this time
weren't the crows there no a lot was
going on
city is really something it's the first
city of new him
and the center of the government and the
military yeah
and being here means i won't miss any
information on baki merchandise